dont 1,6 milliard de tonnes de nourriture
qui se gâtent lors du transport sur le marché,
qui périment dans nos réfrigérateurs
ou qui sont jetées par les supermarchés et les restaurants
à la fin de la journée.
Chaque année, jusqu'à 600 millions de personnes
tombent malades à cause d'aliments contaminés,
d'où l'importance du maintien de la sécurité alimentaire mondiale.
Sans grande surprise, peut-être,
le secteur agricole
est le plus grand consommateur d'eau douce,
avec 70 % de la consommation mondiale.
Vous serez soulagés de savoir
que l'industrie agricole
et le mouvement mondial des ONG, des universités et des entreprises
développent des études approfondies
et des nouvelles technologies
pour résoudre tous ces problèmes.
Beaucoup ont commencé il y a des dizaines d'années.
L'une des innovations les plus récentes en production alimentaire
se développe dans les zones industrielles d'Amérique du Nord,
dans les villes d'Asie,
et même dans les déserts arides du Moyen-Orient.
Il s'agit de l'agriculture contrôlée.
L'agriculture en environnement contrôlé, un terme qui se réfère aux fermes
résistantes aux aléas climatiques,
dans lesquelles on cultive en 3D sur des étagères verticales,
et non en deux dimensions comme dans les fermes conventionnelles.
Ce type de production alimentaire est également appelée
agriculture verticale d'intérieur.
Je m'implique dans cet espace d'agriculture verticale
depuis cinq ans et demi,
en développant des technologies qui rendront ce modèle
plus efficace et abordable.
Cette photo a été prise à l'extérieur d'un conteneur maritime désaffecté
que nous avons converti en ferme verticale
et que nous avons envoyé dans le cœur et la chaleur de Dubaï.
L'agriculture verticale est un phénomène relativement récent,
sur le plan commercial
car le consommateur se soucie davantage de la sécurité alimentaire
et de la provenance des produits
mais aussi car la technologie nécessaire à son développement
est disponible plus rapidement et est moins onéreuse
et le coût global moyen de production est, en réalité, en augmentation
ce qui rend ce type de production plus compétitif.
Donc, si vous souhaitez construire une ferme verticale,
vous devrez remplacer certains éléments agricoles conventionnels
par des substituts artificiels
dont la lumière naturelle du soleil.
Dans les fermes verticales,
on la remplace par un éclairage artificiel comme les LED.
Bien qu'on puisse utiliser plusieurs types de LED,
ici, on a décidé d'installer
des « LED à spectre complet »,
qui ont été optimisées pour la variété de légumes que l'on produisait.
Afin de maximiser la production dans un espace limité,
les fermes verticales emploient des systèmes d'étagères verticales
pour cultiver les légumes,
les plus grandes installations
utilisent des rayonnages de 14 à 16 étages pour produire.
La plupart ont des systèmes hydroponiques ou aéroponiques,
ainsi, au lieu d'utiliser la terre,
on utilise des substituts comme les éponges en polyuréthane,
de la tourbe biodégradable
et même des matériaux inorganiques comme la perlite et les billes d'argile.
Un autre aspect unique de ces fermes,
c'est l'utilisation d'une formule nutritive précise
qui est diffusée et recyclée dans toute l'installation
et directement injectée vers les racines des légumes
pour stimuler leur pousse.
Enfin, ces fermes utilisent
un système de contrôle et d'automatisation sophistiqué
pour booster la productivité,
l'efficacité et la régularité.
Ces outils permettent, en prime,
de produire des aliments davantage traçables et sains.
L'un des avantages évident de ce genre de culture,
c'est la production de légumes sur l'année entière,
vous avez une qualité constante et un rendement prévisible.
Il y a un autre avantage majeur :
l'efficacité importante dans l'exploitation des ressources,
notamment celle de l'eau.
Pour un kilogramme de légumes produit de cette façon,
on économise des centaines de litres d'eau par rapport aux méthodes conventionnelles.
En économisant de l'eau,
on économise également de l'engrais.
Les fermes aux meilleurs rendements
produisent jusqu'à 350 fois plus au m² que les fermes conventionnelles.
L'imperméabilité
permet de contrôler totalement les polluants et les nuisibles entrants,
en éliminant le besoin de recourir aux pesticides chimiques.
Ne vous y méprenez pas,
ces fermes peuvent produire des quantités énormes de nourriture,
l'une des plus grandes fermes
produit 30 000 légumes par jour.
Cependant, comme toute nouvelle technologie ou innovation,
il y a des inconvénients.
Comme vous vous en doutez,
cultiver de cette façon peut être très énergivore.
Elles ne peuvent pas produire de larges variétés de légumes commercialement
et le coût moyen de production reste tout de même relativement élevé.
Afin de résoudre ces problèmes,
certaines des fermes les plus grandes et les plus sophistiquées
font des investissements considérables, notamment en efficacité énergétique.
Afin de réduire la forte consommation d'énergie,
des efforts sont faits pour développer des LED écoénergétiques,
des lasers optimisés pour la croissance des plantes,
et des câbles à fibre optique, comme ceux-ci, peuvent être utilisés
pour canaliser la lumière du soleil à l'intérieur d'une ferme verticale
en journée pour moins dépendre de la lumière artificielle.
Afin de réduire les coûts du travail liés à l'embauche d'une main-d’œuvre
plus complexe, plus urbaine et hautement qualifiée,
la robotique en automation s'est répandue dans les installations à grande échelle.
On peut toujours économiser davantage de ressources.
Construire des fermes verticales au sein et autour des centres urbains
peut aider à raccourcir les chaînes logistiques agricoles
et aider à maintenir la valeur nutritionnelle des légumes.
Il y a aussi des déserts alimentaires dans beaucoup de pays
qui ont peu ou pas accès aux légumes nutritifs
et plus cette industrie mûrira,
plus il sera possible de fournir un accès équitable
à des légumes de bonne qualité et hautement nutritifs,
même dans les communautés les plus défavorisées.
Et enfin, c'est vraiment passionnant pour moi, personnellement,
l'agriculture verticale peut être parfaitement intégrée
dans le paysage urbain
afin de requalifier les infrastructures urbaines vacantes et inutilisées.
C'est ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui.
Les services de covoiturage ont réduit le nombre de voitures sur les routes
et ont considérablement réduit les besoins en stationnement.
Ceci est un ferme qu'on a installée au cœur de Pékin
dans un parking sous-terrain sous-utilisé
pour cultiver des légumes pour les hôtels à proximité.
Les infrastructures vacantes
ne se limitent pas qu'aux projets d'ingénierie civile de grande envergure
mais incluent les espaces restreints comme les coins de restaurants vacants.
Ceci est un exemple de ferme installée
directement dans la cloison d'une entrée d'hôtel.
Les chefs ont des fines herbes et des micropousses fraîches sur place.
Honnêtement, regardez autour de vous
et vous trouverez des espaces inutilisés partout
sous, autour et à l'intérieur des aménagements urbains.
Cette ferme a été installée dans un coin de bureau vide
pour vendre des légumes frais dans les cafés alentour.
J'ai la chance de faire partie de ces projets innovants
et de travailler dans l'industrie agricole
pour rendre des produits frais et nutritifs
plus abordables et accessibles
à tous et partout, très vite je l'espère.
Cela a été un immense plaisir et une belle leçon d'humilité,
et le plus grand défi intellectuel que j'ai relevé.
Maintenant que je vous ai convaincus que l'agriculture peut être plutôt sexy,
vous serez surpris et choqués de savoir
que j'ai toujours du mal
à expliquer comment et pourquoi j'ai décidé de commencer et de continuer
à travailler dans l'industrie agricole.
Mais il y a deux ans, j'ai trouvé une réponse assez unique,
elle était juste sous mon nez.
Vous voyez, j'ai lu un article
qui expliquait comment votre nom,
plus précisément, votre nom de famille,
peut avoir une influence
sur tout, de votre personnalité à votre carrière professionnelle.
Ceci est mon nom de famille japonais :
Oda.
Littéralement, les caractères signifient
« petite ferme ».
(Rires)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)